our goal is to remove a billion tons of
CO2 by 2035 not only that but kind of
removing CO2 from the atmosphere is one
of the only ways that we can address the
carbon dioxide we've already emitted so
we're really really focused on getting
to the root of the problem and actually
tackling the carbon crisis that we're in
right now
heirloom uses naturally Korean minerals
to take CO2 directly out of our air so
what that means is you know as a part of
the carbon cycle
minerals take up CO2 it's a very slow
process and what we've done essentially
is given these minerals superpowers and
that allows them to take up CO2 much
faster than they do geologically so when
thinking about what heirloom does we
take Limestone one of the biggest
reservoirs of CO2 on the planet and we
take its CO2 away that leaves us with a
really thirsty mineral that wants its
CO2 back so we can put that mineral
outside and it'll naturally take up CO2
from the air and reform that Limestone
so we can once again take that CO2 off
of the Limestone and and lay it back out
to capture more CO2 from the air and
then we partner with other companies
that take that CO2 and inject it
underground for permanent storage so we
keep it permanently away from the
atmosphere and it can help us combat
some of the most catastrophic effects of
climate change
I you know got very fascinated in
climate initially through kind of a
social justice lens so when thinking
about
the effects of climate change what you
see is that they disproportionately
affect the world's most vulnerable
populations that have the least to do
with creating the problem so I I'm very
much motivated from that social Equity
piece and I think that for me it's
rooted in why I got interested in
climate change and then my my background
for kind of the research that I've been
doing is in the field of carbon
mineralization which is the act of these
rocks taking up CO2 as well as ways to
take CO2 directly out of the atmosphere
in like an engineered Manner and that's
called direct air capture so I worked at
the intersection of those two fields and
this idea pulls from both of them in
order to create a process that
essentially is like no other
I had the skill set and the expertise
and was very passionate about climate
and was part of the idea inception for
this this process as a part of my
research and I really wanted to make an
impact so that's why I I co-founded this
company is because I knew I had the
skill set I was the right person I was
motivated and excited and I knew that
the process could have a wide sweeping
impact
[Music]
we just closed our series a round
earlier this year we raised on the order
of 70 million dollars for our series a
co-led by Aaron Innovation Capital
breakthrough energy Ventures and carbon
direct that process is I kind of find it
fun and challenging I think it's really
interesting to see what types of
questions people have about what we're
doing and what type of information they
want to see to prove that it's working
and I think those are those are kind of
two different lenses and the fact that I
really enjoy the economic piece and like
how much is our process going to cost
and I think that people are indexing on
that because
a lot of different reasons one is that
you know we're going to have to remove a
significant amount of CO2 from our
atmosphere over the next hundred years
and it can't be expensive if it's
expensive we'll have an aversion to
doing it so it's it's very interesting
to see kind of like from the financial
lens how this has to evolve and what
changes need to be made to get us coming
down that cops curve
[Music]
right now the carbon removal industry is
kind of in its infancy there is not
really regulation around
how you can remove CO2 or what counts as
removing CO2 a lot of what we're
navigating now is how do we create the
infrastructure necessary the rules and
the regulations and the policy that
actually support the industry so right
now in in our field it's primarily
voluntary buyers so people coming in and
saying I want to offset my own carbon
footprint but what we'll really need in
the long term is kind of that policy
piece
we call the company heirloom because the
Earth is a precious object that we want
to pass down from generation to
generation and preserve and I think if
we do that that would be what I want my
legacy to be on earth that not only like
the current children but their
children's children and their children's
children can inhabit and enjoy the same
way that we have but in a more
sustainable way
[Music]